okay welcome back to what's it Wednesday
monster edition this just so you know is
going to be my last what's at Wednesday
for a few months I'll probably come back
to it but I've just I need to find
access to a new skull collection before
I can continue but we'll finish it off
with a bang here figuring out what the
heck this creature from Venezuela was so
the original article of course said that
this is some sort of a chupacabra or the
pet of an alien from outer space
extraterrestrial that of course is not
the case now I was not able to find any
you know actual biologists going through
and explaining what this is so we're
gonna have to do it on our own and all
we have to diagnose this species is this
one single photograph so this is
actually gonna be a pretty tricky thing
to do with 100% accuracy and
unfortunately I can't give you 100%
accuracy in today's identification but
the first thing we need to do is try and
figure out how big this animal is the
only clue that we have from this
photograph are the flies that are all
over this thing's body if these are
normal house flies that would put this
animal at about the size of a house cat
maybe a little bit smaller so it's
actually a pretty small animal one of
the most striking features of it is that
it seems to have a lower jaw that's way
longer than the upper jaw that's
actually just an illusion if you've been
following along with what's it Wednesday
you'll notice that this thing has a
dislocated jaw you're very familiar by
now looking at the jaw bones of animals
and you can tell if this jaw has just
been dislocated and the bottom jaw has
been pulled forward I think that's
really cool it makes it look kind of
like the I don't know if he ever watched
or read the comic spawn there's a
diamond in there I think he's called
like violator or something when he's in
demon form he has a really long under
bite and it it's funny it makes that's
the first thing I thought I wanted to
saw this this chupacabra is oh it's it's
demon from spawn but if we look at the
teeth we see that there are canines
there are probably incisors though it's
hard to see them there are premolars and
there are molars if we look at the hands
the the front paws they're sort of hand
like they're not monkey paws this isn't
some sort of a primate and we can tell
that because monkeys have fingernails
like we do and this thing
has claws I mean the claws are sitting
on top of the fingers in sort of a
fingernail like fashion but they're
definitely claws they're fairly long in
their cylinder like and then if we go to
the tail it's got a very very strong
tail very thick strong tail so these are
our main clues and then followed by all
that this was found in Venezuela we know
from its teeth that it is definitely a
mammal even though it doesn't have fur
that's visible it might have had mange
and lost its fur the fur might have come
off after it died for some reason one
reason or another
that's not very unusual this happens to
mammals all the time they lose their fur
so definitely a mammal should be
something common to Venezuela it's about
the size of a house cat really strong
thick tail this is definitely some sort
of species of opossum the hands are a
match the teeth are a match the tail is
a match and even the nose is a match a
really good match so all of these things
even the nose is pretty decomposed at
this point you can still tell that this
is a little possum nose the huge
zygomatic arches the huge cheekbones are
also very common for opossums and a
little Titan the the the small eyes in
comparison to the head also a very
opossum like feature Oh opossum like
feature I should say now there are over
100 species of opossum in the Americas
and so trying to narrow it down to which
one of those this might be that's where
it gets tricky most likely this is a
common opossum because the common
opossum didelphis a marsupial is the
common opossum is of course the common
opossum in South America so most likely
it is a common opossum there is one
thing that though that tells me this
might not be the case and that is that
the common opossum typically has an
extra molar I can only see three molars
in this picture and it looks like it it
looks like it's consistent on the left
and the right sides of the jaw there's
only three molars there is a fairly big
gap between the last molar and then the
the jawbone the part of the jaar jaar
bond that goes up into the skull so
maybe the
thing is missing a molar and that's not
that unusual
you know I know people that are missing
molars that were just just never grew
them certain molars I know dogs that
just never grew some other teeth so just
not having a tooth you're supposed to
have that's actually fairly common
so even though this is missing one of
its molars it still could be a common
opossum and that's what I'm gonna go
with I'm gonna say that this is
didelphis marsupial as' if you have a
better argument I would love to hear
about that in the comment section but
I'm gonna go with that definitely not a
chupacabra it's definitely not a not a
demon or a pet of an alien this is
definitely an opossum most likely a
common opossum didelphis marsupial is so
that is it for what's it Wednesday for
the time being and we'll be focusing
more time on creationist stuff and more
time on evolution stuff so a lot of you
been asking me for that lately and I
also have this really great two series
that I hope you've seen now with my
nephew that we're doing about about the
elongated skulls of Peru the alien
skills of Peru so check that out so long
for now
you